we have just finished an extraordinary
summit
of nato leaders to address the biggest
threat to our security in a generation
president putin's war against ukraine
the people of ukraine are assisting with
the courage and determination
fighting for the freedom
and for their future
we stand with them
presidency
addressed us with an
impassioned message
thanking nato allies for the significant
support we are providing
and stressing the vital importance of
even more military assistance
today
nato leaders agreed that we must
and will provide further
support to ukraine
we will continue to impose
unprecedented costs on russia
and we will reinforce
allied deterrence and defence
leaders approved
our four new battlegroups in bulgaria
hungary romania and slovakia
these are in addition to the four
already in the baltic countries and
poland
so we have eight
multinational
nato battle groups
now
from the
baltic sea to the black sea
across europe there are 100 000 us
troops
supporting nato efforts
and european allies and canada have also
stepped up
we have 40 000 forces under direct nato
command
mostly in the eastern part of the
alliance
backed by
major air and naval power
including an unprecedented five carrier
strike groups
from the high north to the mediterranean
today nato leaders agreed to reset our
returns and defence for the longer term
to face a new security reality
on land
we will have substantially more forces
in the eastern part of the alliance at
higher redness
with more pre-positioned equipment and
supplies
in the air
we will deploy more jets and strengthen
our integrated air and missile defense
at sea
we will have
carrier strike groups
submarines
and significant numbers of combat ships
on a persistent basis
we will also strengthen our cyber
defenses
and enhance our exercises
focusing on collective defense
and interoperability
i expect we will decide on the details
at our next summit in madrid in june
today
allah leaders also agreed to provide
further support to ukraine
helping to uphold their fundamental
right to
self-defense
allies are also equipping ukraine with
significant military supplies
including anti-tank and air defense
systems and drones
which are proving highly effective
as well as substantial financial and
humanitarian aid
today we agreed to do more
including cyber security assistance
and equipment to help ukraine protect
against biological chemical radiological
and nuclear threats
this could include detection
protection and medical supplies
as well as
training for the community contamination
and crisis management
we are determined to do
all we can to support ukraine
and i welcome the concrete offers
of assistance made by allies today
at the same time
we have a responsibility to ensure the
conflict does not escalate further
because this would
be even more dangerous and more
devastating
allies agreed that we must also increase
our support for other partners at risk
from russia
and
from
at risk from russian threats and
interference including georgia and
bosnia and herzegovina
working together and with
the european union we must help them
uphold their sovereignty and strengthen
their resilience
we also addressed beijing's role in the
crisis
today allied leaders called on china to
refrain from supporting russia's war
effort
china must not provide economic or
military support
for the russian invasion
instead beijing should use its
significant influence on russia
and promote
an
immediate peaceful resolution
allies also agree that belarus must stop
acting as an accomplice to putin's
invasion
at today's meeting leaders reaffirmed
strong our strong commitment to nato's
open door policy under article 10 of the
washington treaty
nato enlargement has been an historic
success
spreading democracy freedom and
prosperity across europe
one month
since the start of russia's invasion of
ukraine
nato's security environment has
fundamentally changed for the long haul
and we are responding
but security but security does not come
for free
and doing war will cost more
so nato leaders agreed to read double
efforts
to meet the defense investment pledge we
made in 2014
allies will submit additional plans on
how to meet the pledge in time for the
madrid summit in june
and i welcome that a number of allies
today announced plans for significant
increases
in defence spending
at this dangerous time transatlantic
unity and solati
are vital europe and north america are
standing and will continue to stand
strong together in nato